what up what up what up what up it's
your boy et that's right yours truly
when you want to succeed as bad as you
want to breathe then you'll be
successful everyone what's up man
need motivation
what's a top ten with a billion nation
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
that there's something greater inside
you as well you have Michael Jordan
level talent at something so get ready
to pay the price
find your gift and wanted bad enough
with Eric Thomas and my take on his top
50 rules are successful you too to give
you the confidence motivation and belief
that you need
ok let's kick it off with rule number
one pay the price I just don't think
people understand how hard you have to
work to make your dreams become a
reality you know like I think people get
so excited about the dream and part that
they have no idea like what it really
takes and so I need you to be a huge
favorite I need you to understand number
one that every dream you have will
become a reality but the first thing you
realize you have to realize is you will
have to pay the price there is a price
tag to greatness it's not free they not
handing it out your mama can't give it
to you your daddy can't give it to you
but god bless the child that's got its
own and so I was in Montgomery last week
guys and I went to the opening of the
new memorial and they showed the
different individuals who had been
lynched and why they had been lynched
and what county they came from
[Music]
and as I was in Montgomery I kept seeing
Rosa Parks listen to me very carefully
guys oh listen to me very carefully she
had to pay a price and so they said to
Rosa you can't see here Rosa said I'm
gonna pay the price they said if you do
not get up Rosa said I ain't getting up
I've been working real low I've been
working real hard I'm not getting up and
they arrested her and guess what Rosa is
great but she's prey to pay the price so
what makes it special for me is that
Rosa Parks is not only an icon Rosa
Parks not only represents having a dream
and not only having a dream but having
to grind for that dream like going to
prison for that dream having to walk 381
days plus for that dream I want to say
to the Millennials you are not entitled
to anything you are not if you go get
anything you will have to work for every
single thing you get and you got to work
every single day rule number two find
your gift when did you know hey this is
something different about me I can
really speak here this is something
unique freshman year in college don't
laugh all right
freshman year in college me and my boys
start like this like Christian like
organizations or every Tuesday Thursday
and Sunday we'd speak now they didn't
let me speak initially okay because I
was a high school dropout rough around
the edges like I wasn't really polished
right and so but here's a good thing is
you know you stay home was a gift so we
did it every Tuesday Thursday Sunday so
at some point the guys couldn't make the
appointment so so I was like always the
host of the show so when they didn't
show up yes they like when we bring a
surah so to speak I'm like nah no you're
not I'm hosted so this is my shot right
here the best of Villa ability is
availability
ergh what there Trey what there I'm like
finally three four months into it I'm
like I I'm no I mean it cuz they got
hair I don't you know and my first
message was pimpin ain't easy but
somebody's got to do it
that was my first message search me you
had to church me I pimpin ain't easy but
somebody's gotta do it I said don't
laugh
what but this is how I knew I had
something because people were like yo
nobody's ever and so I talked about how
the devil is trying to pimp us and and
you know and I just took that whole
angle and in my second message just blew
up was how many licks does it take to
get to the center of a sucker you know
and so everybody was just like yo
brother it's different like this is not
a normal preacher it's not the normal
delivery the energy is kind of different
so while adults weren't really fooling
with me a lot of guys who were like oh
really do that Church stuff I won't do
that kind of stuff we're not into that
and what was unique about and I'm glad
you asked nobody's ever asked for this
what was unique is that we did at the
bell tower which was in the center of
the campus so you had to pass it to go
anywhere so it's cash like you I wasn't
coming to no spiritual event but I would
hear that loud voice and that passion
and I heard you know so they would just
walk over like yeah what is he talking
about pimping ain't easy and it was at
that point when I saw non church regular
people jeans t-shirts coming by and when
I would speak stop I was like yo E you
got you got something yeah you got
something rule number three wanted daddy
enough I need you to want it as bad as
you want to breathe listen to me very
closely
listen to me when I wrote my dreams and
my goals down look when I wrote my
dreams and my goals down take a look at
it guys when you want to succeed as bad
as you want to breathe I'm telling y'all
I'm telling y'all the 4-year degree with
the Masters the PhD when I went after it
I'm showing you're right where I
graduated from that's why I'm standing
here because I need y'all to see it I
need y'all to see where I walked across
the stage just where I did it y'all I
wanted as bad as I wanted to breathe I
got up in the morning and I walked them
down
give me before I get out of here you
ain't got him with you you ain't gotta
had the best hand in life I'm leaving
you with this you ain't gotta had the
best hand in life you ain't got to start
with the two-parent background
you ain't got to start with wealth you
ain't got to start with your parents
graduated it's not the hand that you
dealt you got rich kids who own drugs
you got rich kids who committed suicide
you got rich kids who who don't know
their purpose in life it's not the hand
that you were dealt baby it's how you
play your hand it's your boy ichi-san if
it was easy to do everybody would do it
I'm not saying it's gonna be easy but
you have what it takes if you listen it
to make it happen so do me a favor get
up get out and go get something with you
number four have big dreams I want you
to live the life you were meant to live
you hear me
not the life that was given to you I'm a
high school dropout cuz that's the life
my daddy gave me but I've been made
almost 28 years and two kids by the same
woman which is not my experience
I got brothers and sisters none of us
had the same parents because I made up
in my mind that's the life y'all gave me
I'm not I'm not taking that no more I
don't want I don't want to be on crack
I've never drank I never smoked and I'm
not against it I just didn't do it
because my family was doing it and they
wasn't winning doing it uncle died of
cirrhosis of the liver I'm like bruh I'm
not going out like that
uncle's in prison I'm not going I wasn't
meant to be in prison I got married in
19 y'all's meant to live with a woman
I'm not I'm not
I'm a Texas brothers being real it's
some dudes they like I'm hardcore I'm
not hard I promise you I'm not hard I
wanna be with no dudes all day every day
nah I'm gonna need a break I'm gonna
need a break from that I'm just being
real I'm gonna need a break for me and
my man in the same bunk and I ain't got
no privacy I'm gonna need a break from
that I'm just being real I'm gonna need
a break from prison food
imma need my grandma cooking at some
point I'm just being real just be honest
when you walk out of here some of you
are not transitioning because you okay
with the life you have and I'm telling
you right when I walk out I want to be
an example of you can start from
wherever and get to wherever you want to
get to that's what I'm asking you to do
what fuels you the reason why you so
lazy is not because you don't have the
ability you so lazy because your dream
so small also if you want to have more
confidence check out my 254 series they
are free the links to join are in the
description below freshman year in
college me and my boys start like this
like Christian like organizations get
that gold get that dream and I'm just
been telling you driving and driving and
driving and driving what I've been
talking about is consistency I have
boundaries rule number five get to know
people for me it's like when you get
around people and you spend enough time
with people to see what people want and
then you give them what they need to me
that's what it's all about you know so
it's like we got to get out of this this
is what I want to talk about or this is
what I want to say or this is how one
it's like no my idols mother Teresa like
I use just to watch her movement right
and she was the lowest on a pecking
order when you talk about preaching with
an archbishop she won the Pope she was a
nun oh yeah you know who she is
and I would watch her and she would see
okay here the needs of the people when I
watched monitor King this dude could
have easily been like a millionaire
living in a he moved and with the people
and said hey I'm gonna give up my life
and what I want to do to help so for me
it's like you can't affect the person if
you don't know what they want so you
guys spent enough time with people just
chilling with people hanging out with
people that's why I was deep there's
like it's not a studio I'm like oh
where's crib this won't be for
just because they eat those like we're
in your house this way you live I can
say this energy already ended in the
space you know and spirits you know
already in the place so for me it's like
you gotta get to know the people yeah
spend time with the people and then once
you find out what they need you like a
cow you chew it up chew it up chew it up
chew it up you study it you study and
then when you get to them you give them
what they need and of course they're
gonna be excited is because what they
need rule number six take the shot
stop saying I'm not good enough stop
saying my family we don't do this like
stop with the excuses and take the
opportunity that's given to you shoot
the doggone shot you wide open take this
shot I need you to hear me very
carefully when he told me I would be
played I never shared this with my
friends but I will wake up in that
abandoned building and I would pretend
that I was gonna be great as I walked up
and down those lonely streets I would
pretend to myself and I was gonna be
great I need you to me a favor before
the actual dream becomes a reality I
need you to wake up every single day I
need you to eat the dream I need you to
sleep to dream I need you to talk to
dream because some days you're not gonna
feel like get up and the dream is gonna
push you some day you're not gonna feel
like keep going but the dream is going
to push you rule number seven don't be
envious don't be envious of individuals
who in your life your homeboys your
homegirls like we're not talking about
haters right now with so much of people
you love stop looking at everybody
else's life right now y'all guys do me a
favor you gotta be tunnel vision right
you can't are my man doing this my
homegirl doing this she graduated he got
a job I don't got a job and like she
prize for anything my man prize but I
thought look listen to me
maybe nobody else had the hand that life
dealt them don't envy nobody else my boy
joy kibble my sophomore year he left
college right went to go sing with take
SIG's brat Grammy award-winning take six
are you hearing me I never went to my
boy critter hated on my boy when I went
I was like dude I was like not only in
my dreams like in my head not only am I
dream something I'm talking about but I
got a homeboy who lorded rule number
eight do it for the love look this was
wrong with this generation if you're
doing it for money you cutting it on and
all hmm if you're doing it for money if
they ain't giving you bread that mean
you ain't gonna come clean yes that mean
you ain't gonna give 120% so that's why
I do it for the love of the game because
that just mean every time I do it I'm
gonna be fired who make the most money
the the basketball player not that could
put up 40 the dude that could put up the
big numbers and do it consistently I
can't pay a dude who gonna put up 30 in
one game then he gonna put a 5 in
another one mmm I can't build my team
around inconsistency but if you could
score 17 a night and I know you can give
me that 50 games out of 82 I can reveal
something around that so for me young
people listen to me you temper minnow if
you can only do it for money and if you
temper minnow it just don't mean I can I
don't know when I can count on you and
we can't make money if I don't know when
I can count on you so for me it's that's
why I was at the camp murdering it
because I don't know who in the room who
could give me another opportunity rule
number nine surround yourself with
greatness what is it that you did that's
separate issue from everybody else that
did what you did so your motivational
speaker and there are other people in
the game and I respect everything that
you and everybody who follows you but
what exactly did you do that separated
you and your work ethic and everything
else so the first thing I did was
literally a lot of people go to church I
built a relationship with the Creator I
said look I'm gonna put you first I
messed up apparently I didn't know I
didn't do it right I'm gonna give you a
shot now to run my life and don't do
don't mess it up like I messed it up so
I'm giving it to you fully we're not
gonna play with it you can have it
completely second thing I did was I got
reading my wife when I was in in church
relationships are everything who you
hang with yeah who you hang with who you
who you make your right here that's that
I don't care nothing about read and
study and doing it look dad not to do it
nothing you you are nothing but the sum
total of the people that you're closest
to all right so you got to get with the
right I got with Dede and Dede said look
I'm going to college you're a high
school dropout when I go to college I'm
not dating no high school dropout you
either get a GED and follow me to
college on breaking up with you the
first word I use when I came out and I
talked about gas and the car was what
fuel that was fuel but I'm not looking
to me I might be stupid but I ain't done
being real I might be stupid but I ain't
done bro I knew my girl weren't about to
go to no college for four years yes huh
yo said I stupid she ain't about to go
to college before year around all them
dudes who want to be doctors and lawyers
and teachers and gonna come back to me
and for she not gonna graduate and come
home to a high school dropout and be
like I'm back I was like the only way
that I'm gonna keep her to go get this
GED and follow and so I'm telling you
you hang around the right people they
will give you dreams for yourself that
you didn't have for yourself they will
create expectations for you that you
didn't expect and then finally what
makes me different than anybody else is
when you get the opportunity from day
one you stay you get hungry day one and
you stay hungry
you number ten be intentional everything
is intentional come on intentional you
got to be intentional and deliberate and
everybody that's running what you got to
be intentional delivery see this is what
I don't do I don't hang with people you
can only get up when they got something
to motivate them that's not something I
wanna hang out with I wanna hang out
what to do in Boston you can kill them
and Detroit you can kill them in Toronto
you can bring the noise are you here
when I'm telling you I'm gonna hang with
somebody I don't care what the
I don't care what the situation you put
it on your back and you like let's go I
don't work with people who count on me
to put up 50 point I run with people who
put up video I put up piggy back what up
and we murder you that's why I respect
mic sorry look at some highlights y'all
magic was the man Larry Bird with man
Doubront come up black mama the man go
back and look at some highlights y'all
y'all go back and look at the highlights
- MJ go look at the highlights oh look
at that intensity my man head go look at
the highlights watch Jordan y66 he's
trying to hear this boom and looked at
you like boom he was shooting he was the
only one that make a check he started
that he's making Jam assassination
[Music]
history who done for you it didn't stop
you the only one offensive Massacre and
defensive assassination I'll take it
from you
I'll rip it to you and you'll watch me
go down boom now I make you proud shut
up
I'll take them off the game doll rule
number 11 fight I know many of you saw
this game they were down by 20 they were
down by 20 that's pretty much down by 20
and Golden State No
down by 20 away so boom multiple
businesses right so but before this
happened if anybody's been studying him
closely what happened before this game
happened 77 three-pointers in a row this
boy made 77 three-point shots in
practice they were down by 20 points he
came back and won the game but you might
have missed it
take him to the slide see do you see it
he's shooting a three-pointer with his
eyes closed they show that on
SportsCenter the boy's eyes is closed
with the three muscle memory his eyes
his pose what was he thinking about he
was thinking about in practice one in
practice 277 and he started saying to
himself we down by three points three
times seven is twenty-one
let me give him the business one defense
- defense guys I'm worried about just
give me the rock
you sure remember what I did in practice
seconds left he's not even at home he
away from home he got his eyes closed
with one of the best defenders checking
them
you've been lazy your whole life and now
somebody told you you could make six
figures and you go knock on the door a
hundred times and your body say you a
lot you ain't never gave 100% and/or
they're not gonna do a hundred times
you're gonna have to get 120 to get up
out of here you can't do this and you
gonna have to fight and fight and fight
and fight and most of you won't be
successful not because you can't do it
but you can't outlash oh oh you long
enough to get to your new
I'm leaving I'm gonna say it again you
can't get past oh oh you to get to your
new you every time you dedicate yourself
just my year I'm gonna make it happen
you don't make it happen this kid didn't
take his team to the most wins this year
because of what he does in the game
I'm accounting for you one defense
somebody tell me I'm sorry Davis how
tall this Davis 1672 wingspan he right
there
I see somebody else looked like a small
forward a small forward inside there
right there
I got another guy coming around right
there he got his eyes closed and he
shoots hope this is your year this is
your year
this is your year this is your moment
you saw your boy et do it this is your
year this is your moment
if not you who have not not win this is
you baby ain't nobody stopping you but
you ain't nobody stop you but you you
not a bridge that acting like you're not
average while you being average you not
a prett why are you being good when
you're not good you grades you
phenomenal when you gonna step up to the
plate
you won't let a high school dropout
somebody that lived in banded buildings
somebody ate out of trash I'll do you I
couldn't hardly read when I got to
college you gonna let me out do you
you're greater than that rule number 12
make your breakthrough you want to break
or you want breakthroughs come on mask
you again you want to break you crowd
about you want to break do you want to
break or break - listen I have lost
loved ones male friend I've gotten so
many calls about people duck
look I've had so many setback setbacks I
never experienced I had so many phone
calls so many disappoint like listen to
me very close this has been a
challenging year and I'm like God how
many more people he said sad you wanna
play or you want to wake up thank God I
can't take them with God it's just
someone's gonna God can I take a break
he say you wanna break or you wanna play
through and I'm asking you this in order
to get a break through no break you got
a grind grind grind you got to go
through setbacks and disappointments you
got to go through it so it's not gonna
be easy but your boy et I said God I'd
rather take my breakthrough gonna take a
break so I need you to get through to
get through I need you girl I need you
to power through it I need you to pray
through it I need you encourage yourself
through I need you to call you
accountability for I didn't you do
whatever it takes but you better not
quit on me because if you don't take a
break I promise you
your breakthrough is coming rule number
13 pay the price
so here's number three what piss me off
sometimes when I'm dealing with y'all
whoop it's me off yep I'm gonna tell the
truth
right so I get upset because y'all think
everybody got a like that you doing and
everybody gotta like you I go for real
you got to get to a point when you like
yo this is what I want to do and I'm
gonna do it but watch me when you do
that ah when you do that you gotta be
willing to better fight so I tell you
all the time
I couldn't stand some of the stuff my
parents wanted me to do guess what I
left at 16 what was the price I paid I'm
paying homeless I'm paying eating out of
trash cans
I paid living in abandoned buildings by
myself I paid being around my friends
thinking that's right stinking against
what my boy jokes me I was the last and
stop gotta clean but you know what I
paid the price
you feel me I paid the price rule number
14 have a growth mindset one thing that
bothers me like right now in life you
know life would be so great for me man I
promise you if I could fix this one
thing but my biggest challenge is he
said the fixed mindset you know the
growth mindset is that I gotta hang with
people that don't have my mindset man
it's just so it's just so hard man you
know because you know people think you
bougie
I'm not trying to be bougie you know but
a lot of my people that I love I'm late
myself I spend time you know away from a
lot of people and it's like y'all ain't
mad at y'all but I want to win 82 games
man I want to win 82 games I want to win
every playoff get I want to sweep every
doggone team I want to win the doggone
championship and you get with people who
make it to the league if they make it
and that's enough for them and a lot of
people like you know my I had a
conversation my boy called me the other
day and it just was so rough you know
because it was like yo ain't trying to
lead none of y'all but I ain't trying to
die being with y'all you know I'm saying
like and I got a make what a lot of
humans don't realize I got to make so
many sacrifices to be with you you know
I'm saying anything and it ain't like
I'm trying to be better than you or I'm
a bad dude but like let's just be real
Josh we stand at the montage you know
I'm saying my girl was like we spent a
lot like did he sit down like she was
like it cost for three days I have a
long we stay at 10 grand
I'm like no question yeah so it ain't
like I got nothin against nobody Josh
but when I travel I don't want to be a
dollar day in Express yeah no question I
did that already I paid my dues I stayed
I stayed in the motel 6 bro I was in the
looking to when I first started speaking
do you feel me and I started when I was
bruh we was driving 1012 hours yeah 16
hours I don't want to do that at 47 and
the fact that you didn't grow or you
want to stay where you are
I'm not mad at you but I get I get angry
with people because you trying to make
me feel bad because I I want to grow
bright like I wake up every day and I
want to be better than what I was the
day before so if I go to a restaurant
and I want to I want eggs Brown went to
a restaurant the other day it was like 3
o'clock in the afternoon but I was at
Wyndham Hotel where they taint oh no we
don't serve eggs yeah they not own that
they like we're here for you that's the
difference in the hotel Holiday Inn
Express they telling me we'll serve that
we only sir that from 6:00 to 11:00
the montage they like you want scrambled
eggs with cheese okay how many eggs you
want okay what else do you eat well I'm
each the soy we got soy - we got
everything
and don't come downstairs bring it down
good bring it up so I just want to say
you know for real man that's the one
thing in my life right now that that if
I had a magic wand I would fix I want to
be with everybody yeah but I can't be
around average and you can't be mad at
me because I don't it's like what Jamal
said all right want to get property
that's what he does I don't want to be
around people who don't want to take
risks yeah
not because I'm mad at you but you you
bottle me up yeah you making me not
right I want to fly with number 15 get
out of a cage there's probably about six
seven years ago I felt like a cage
animal y'all feel like a caged lion are
you hearing me like I felt cage all I
feel like the people that were over me
like they wouldn't let it do its thing
real job see this right here like I
didn't have this opportunity like I
could see it but I was Kelly's like it
was close I could touch it I could smell
it I can see it but I couldn't get to it
and I asked myself by ET how are you
gonna be a caged animal like will y'all
got to hear what I'm telling you there
those of you who are changed and you got
the key and you got to make up in your
mind that the people who holding you
down you're not gonna let them hold you
down the moon look I'm not even on the
victim stuff I'm saying you got to get
to a point well you like y'all eat you a
caged animal what you gonna do about it
and I said I'm gonna go to school for it
I'm gonna get every single degree I can
get I'm gonna use YouTube I'm going to
do free cheesy IMS look I'm gonna go to
schools for free I would do whatever I
gotta do to get out this cave and look
y'all ETA ETA ETA gage Bobo y'all see
this Hey
and this ain't something I'm doing every
now and then this is my life now
so be ready to stop being the caged lion
cage gorilla cage whatever you see
yourself as if you ready to stop being
caged you want to be free
listen to me the person has got you in
bondage dangle never you the key you
gotta take you rule number 16 count the
cost like you ain't got to be in love
with everything you do sometimes y'all
feel like all right so I ain't feeling
this way ain't gonna do it
like for real y'all feel like ain't
feelin school I don't feel like taking a
certain job you think I wanted to take
every single job I took you think I
wanted the job at McDonald's the job at
Burger King you think I wanted to watch
the toilets at the Olive Garden
you think I wanted to wipe somebody else
urine up right and scrub somebody else's
feces that's what you think but I had a
son I had a daughter I had a wife I'm
just being real to all my Millennials
you just can't do what you in love with
what you're interested in
sometimes you have to do what you don't
want to
so you can live like you want to live
all right so do me a favor like count
the cost so this point to help you reach
your goal even if you don't like it do
it anyway rule number 17 take the shot
like if somebody gets you out take it
like I don't care how hard it is how
difficult if you have somebody that's
willing to rock with you hold your hand
in the process encourage you motivate
you inspire you like stop saying I'm not
good enough stop saying my family we
don't do this like stop with the excuses
and take the opportunity that's given to
you shoot the doggone shot you wide open
take this shot I need you to hear me
very carefully when he told me I would
be break I never shared this with my
friends but I will wake up in that
abandoned building and I would pretend
that I was going to be great
as I walked up and down those lonely
streets I would pretend to myself and I
was gonna be great I need you to do me a
favor before the actual dream becomes a
reality I need you to wake up every
single day I need you to eat the dream I
need you to sleep the dream I need you
to talk to dream because some days
you're not gonna feel like get up and
the dreamers don't push it
some days you're not gonna feel like
keep going but the dream is going to
push you
rule number 18 look out for yourself I
realize that you know it's okay to look
out for yourself mm-hmm
you know I'm saying like like I put in a
lot of working for the world I bless the
world
you know I'm said if I stop today I
probably bless the world more than the
average human being there's no clutch to
work yeah you know I'm saying it's like
the last you know however many years I
got like it's over it's okay to go
gorilla like it's okay to it's okay to
go beast mode
yeah it's okay yeah I'm just saying it's
okay you know I'm saying I feel like for
real I'm at a point where I feel like
God will say to me today well done good
and faithful servant like what I call
you to do yeah you you took it and you
ran with it
but now I need you to look out for you
you know I'm saying in a way that nobody
else is gonna look out for you because
it's you you know and I think when you
do what I do you make the you make the
mistake when you're younger thinking you
pouring all these people they're just
gonna automatically turn
pour into you now and it don't work like
that not even in a bad way but nobody
even knows what you need first and
foremost no other human even knows what
you need they not in you to know what
you need you know so they're just
certain opportunities I would be like
nope I'm not gonna do that because this
is gonna take me away from being a
servant and it's like yo you served
enough you know I'm saying I look at I
look at my mentor and that's the one
thing that I that I'm hurt for it's like
you know he will pass and have put 70
years in the lesson people that I don't
know if he ever got to do this I don't
know if he was ever able to rent
something out for a month and come and
enjoy the fruits of his labor only if
only to if I was the only person that he
blessed you know I'm saying he would
have done a great work and he never got
to rest you know for years and enjoy the
fruits of his labor but I'm like yo I'm
not going out like that
yeah you know because if you if not in a
bad way for so many people are in need
I'll never forget that there was a
scripture where they was telling Jesus
like we need whatever whatever that why
are you doing this and that and why you
ain't doing that seems like the poor
will always be among us you know I'm
saying like I'm with the disciples right
now that's when I focus and I realize
now the ship has to be from the masses
you know to a select group and my wife
and my kids and my mom right now is a
part of that you know so for me like I
always say it ain't like I don't care
what the assessments say I'm from
Chicago and Detroit it ain't like I
don't got gorillas like you don't make
it on the streets of Detroit being soft
you know I'm saying you don't you're not
hold on yeah yeah yeah you know you're
not homeless living in abandoned
building being soft yeah but I always
felt like I had to look out for others
first yeah and I put myself second and I
and I don't have no regrets but I'm
still young and I still got a whole life
like Serena's here yesterday I ain't
about to retire no time soon my career
is just getting started
and just watching you Josh you know and
just the things you've exposed me to
it's like II these next 30 go get these
Championships no no go rack up the bank
account go rack up the houses go wrap up
rack up the trips huh you know I'm
saying but again for those of you who
are listening who are your others focus
you'll put in your work like you want
lay down at the end of the day because
you are about others and you need to go
to sleep knowing that you took care of
it but at some point you got to put a
stop to that because LeBron could have
been in Cleveland for the rest of his
life he gave him a championship he
brought that city what he what he needed
to do in his heart he brought that city
that championship now I feel good that
LeBron is going out and LeBron bout to
go to LA and do movies and put himself
and his family in a position where his
legacy
rule number 19 stop whining start
grinding why did it start crying you
can't cry about what it takes a plan to
accomplish let me sit in Florida just in
case you don't get it you can't spend
money and time being emotional when it
requires a plan you feel me like you
can't give your emotions to something
every bar plan so what you crying about
you got to get up and grind does it
require more money go put a plan
together to make more money does it
require like a network then find those
people right like I'm just telling you
like don't worry about something that
you can work about use your energy on
coming up with a map of master plan
ain't never sweat inside my pants so I'm
thinking of a master plan
rule number 20 level up come on got a
question for you are you ready to play
at this level come on win you talk come
on baby arm city do you see it show some
b-roll y'all
[Music]
are you ready to play at this level I
never asked you can you play at this
level
I never asked you that I know you can
play at this level I don't care what
they told you I don't care where you
come from I don't care what you've seen
no you don't have to do what your family
did you don't have to accept the life
that was given to you I just got a
question for you you ready to play at
this level you have what it takes to
play at this level but the question is
can you play at this level do you have a
heart do you have the perseverance do
you have a commitment do you add a
consistency and let me tell you
something before I go every house you
see out here somebody living in it and
guess what they human just like you so
before I get out of here et got a
question for you
are you writing the play are you I'm
sorry I should have to the part are you
ready to play at this level and if you
ready to play at this level I'll see you
on top so do me a favor stop making
excuses and make the rest of your life
the best let's go rule number 21
surround yourself with greatness and
something happens no matter who you are
if you're average or if you're good when
you get around greatness and you stay
around greatness you start listening the
great podcast and reading great books
and you start hanging around great
people when you start becoming a part of
great masterminds guys you just evolved
and I don't know what happened but every
year I went from a high school dropout
and homeless so I started to be coming
every single day more of Who I am and I
can't believe it my next goal is to win
the Nobel Prize why I had to come up
with something listen to me you have to
be careful when you hang around average
people all they're going to do is tell
you what they can't do and that's okay
that they can't do it but that has
absolutely nothing to do with us we can
go from being homeless and high school
dropouts to having ph d--'s writing
books and becoming the voice of a
generation
we can do whatever we believe we can do
and we don't need anybody's permission
to do it but ours
rule number 22 applying what you learn
you know you got to be careful what I
this motivation and the books you read
yeah but you got to be careful that
you're not doing it
like for entertainment you feel me and I
think a lot of you do it for
entertainment so it's like I'm watching
Serina play that's purely other than the
fact that I'm gonna take some of the
content and use it you know the speak
that's purely entertainment I'm just
watching her do what she do that's pure
entertainment and so for some of you
when you when you listen to motivation
you're not using it to fuel you you feel
me but you need to use it to fuel you so
let's just say you can do real estate
and you scared like you should you
should be listening to specific stuff
that's gonna tell you don't be afraid
take risk let the Rope go let the neck
go like that's what you should be
listening to not wrist wrap dumb stuff
you know I'm saying like we put stuff
out but we're putting it out because
that's what we do we just put stuff out
but you got to get a catalogue and say
alright I'm fearful or I don't got that
dawg
and if you doing business you gotta have
that dawg so you just gotta listen to a
whole bunch of stuff I see people walk
around with the t-shirts you I look
yourself in the mirror I got that dog
like whatever it is you need then when
you give books I'm tired of people like
oh it's like a like a keeping up with
the Joneses not like you know what book
you read for what wait it's like you
telling me what book you read for what
like just so you can sound deep you're
not doing them with the information you
feel me like you just trying to be like
in conversation like drinking coffee and
say oh yeah I read that with grit
I read grit grit was phenomenal but you
don't got no more grit I'm just saying
you don't have no more grease than you
started when you first read the book so
it's like instead of reading a book and
trying to be deep like what is the book
saying like how do you acquire grit if
you don't got none do me a favor stop
reading to be deep right some of y'all
watching Power you don't got no more
power after watching power are you gonna
watch it Rock watch what episode
that ain't necessarily my thing but I'm
saying if you're gonna watch it from
what I'm hearing it's a it's some cats
on there who straight up gangsters so if
you're gonna watch it be gangsters like
for real don't watch it and don't be
gangster if you're gonna watch it and
you gonna put that stuff in your spirit
if you're gonna watch The Godfather
people I watch The Godfather for what
what did you watch The Godfather for
what did you learn when you was watching
it you watch Scarface what'd you learn I
learned some stuff from Scarface flat
out flat out I learned some stuff right
and my wife getting me all the time you
don't I'm like yo I've seen the movie I
grew up in hood flat out and system
something I'm conscious I'm aware of so
I'm so ain't no dough gonna get knocked
down on me ain't gonna get shot up you
understand what I'm telling you like I'm
aware always of what's happening you
feel me so don't be why I watched our
face I went to the movie and saw it I
still remember the movie to this day I
still remember when my with the women
thing how the woman theme miss the whole
messed a whole little swag up though I
remember his new jack city and stuff
happen where the power wasn't equal and
that I'm ice I watch the movie so you
watching it but you ain't paying
attention to it and I'm paying attention
so stop watching that's up and not doing
them with it remember 23 find your dream
we go to school for all these years and
they never really show us the importance
of dreaming right
I look at school and I'm like yo the way
school is design is this designing you
to be prepared to work for somebody else
and I'm not even upset with that but
there's little of you that you get right
y'all got to work with me because this
is deep right so I said to my son I said
to my son son I got to ask you a
question like and I'm being serious I
said do you believe you created yourself
he was like what I like do you believe
created yourself he said no I said do
you believe there's a creator he said of
course I do I said don't do that don't
don't do the dad thing cuz You Know Who
I am and you know like I'm about that
life
like don't answer like I'm asking you
for real you owe me nothing this is you
do you believe that there's something
out here that's bigger than you he said
of course I do dad I said do you believe
as a human being not in a braggadocious
way but that you are
the greatest level of all creation he's
like you mean like over a deer
I was like yeah a deer hit me like you
mean better than the ego on my ear like
a ego he was like of course because we
could make decision we can do things I
said okay okay I just wanna go back
again you don't believe you were created
he said no but you believe there's a
higher power
he was like yeah and and I said okay
okay okay you believe it's a human you
powerful he was like a forest I say so
as a human do you believe you were just
worn to being a relationship have sex
and have money and buy stuff he was like
mmm no I guess it's something bigger
than that dad it's like I guess the
other thing is a calling I said well if
you believe that why have you never gone
after your calling why you spent so much
time worrying about a relationship why
you spent so much time so worried about
money and cars and stuff if you really
believe what you just told me that as a
human is something greater than that
then weren't you own that he was like I
don't know I said cuz here's the trick
son if you get this in that you still
might not get you I'm just being real
weird to my time I think it's a fabulous
place it's great but I didn't walk in
there like ah like it was really the the
mountains that made me go whoa it was
really when I saw the birds flying that
I was like unbelievable
it wasn't really the room that I was
like this is the great as a matter of
fact the guy was getting on my nerve I
guess when you pay money to go there
they got to try to do the whole
personable thing I'm like I'm on the
call please just give me the keys I go
to my room and if I have some problems
when I get to my room I will call you so
I'm having a conversation with my son
saying son do me a huge favor don't go
after the low-hanging fruit here's the
deal if you get to the top of the tree
all the flew from the bottom of the top
is gonna be their son so I don't need
you focusing on cars and money and stuff
you're gonna get dads I need you to
focus on why you were born in the first
place why are you here on earth for this
particular time what are you doing
here anybody can buy a car son animals
get in relationships animals have sex
you have kid its son it's got to be
deeper than that if you're higher than
humans then why you here you got to do
more than what animals do and so when
they talked about dreams and legacy I
was like yo people don't get it write
this down your DNA is in your dream your
DNA is in your dream so so it was funny
I was walking with CJ father the other
day and we were talking and I promise
y'all like every single time we talk I
don't care when it is I don't care how
long we talk we always talk about the
relationship he had with his father and
and and I know that the impact that it
had on his kid listen to me his DNA his
dream his DNA is family like that's all
he cared about is his son like when we
go out I never saw him dressed like a
certain way like he's never like hold on
II I got to get the polo shirt and every
time I talk to him it's the same thing
his DNA his dream his DNA his kids has
formed his life it is formed who he is
as a man and mostly y'all chasing stuff
you don't realize your dreams are so
important because your DNA who you are
as a person is wrapped up in your dreams
and what this world is done to you is
take that from you because they know if
you know who your drew you are and you
get your dream you're probably not gonna
work for most of them you're probably
not gonna do most of the dumb stuff it's
like for real if you knew who you if you
knew your dreams and you knew and you
followed your dreams you followed your
dealing most of you probably would have
never been on drugs I've never met a
person before who knew who they were and
was on drugs remember 24 grind people
say ey you still getting up so early
morning 3 o'clock because I was on I was
on the beach with my wife not too long
ago we was holding hands walking up the
beach and my wife said I know it was
hard for me to quit my job but promise
me I'll never have to go back to work
again
[Music]
adrián let me tell you some Adrienne
when she said that I was like you'll eat
when you get home you got a grind bro
you might have to start getting up at
2:30 you might might even go to sleep
right that's it I'm just saying I'm tell
you I never did this before I started
looking at my booking gigs I realized
like I say no to 750 to 1000 gigs a
month I started doing my homework yo I
start man I was just with this dude got
the top podcast in the world and I
started doing my homework
I paid a couple people do some homework
for me I called my man he's like you'll
eat
you ain't operating off 10% of yo here's
I yo he for real bruh I've been with the
best
don't nobody communicate he like yo most
dudes and I they can only talk to one
group E he like yo you it don't make a
different way age you don't didn't make
a difference with ethnic background he
like yo he you the greatest communicator
on the earth right now you only operate
now about 10% I was like you always
trying to go to work I'm telling you
I've been thinking I've been making
calls that's what I'm asking you to do
what fuse you the reason why you so lazy
is not because you don't have the
ability you so lazy cuz your dream so
small yo dreams are so slow rule number
25 don't sabotage yourself I'm thinking
about people sitting here right now like
yo thrill you got a car that you should
have because the car now is a symbol is
it's a symbol of success instead of just
getting the whip that's gonna get you
from A to B and you can't say 500 or
it's like I said people look at my crib
like yoki I can't believe you live there
but for me more is what you said I was
always on that if I live under my means
I'm gonna always have money so the more
money I make the more money I'm gonna
make cuz I ain't spending no more money
you thought I'm saying and so I don't
have a TV I barely got a 72 inch TV on
the wall that my wife won
I brushed she went shopping there's been
a hundred dollars that some little
furniture store a spot and they called
it like yo we got a TV for it she
thought it was playing it like no got TV
for you but I had that same
plasma that was sweet when I first
bought it 10 years ago on the wall but
it's to your point it's like I don't
need to make more money if I stop
spinning it you know I'm saying about I
don't have to get a new car every year I
don't have to get a new I don't have a
watch I don't have no anything I missed
it's like I did want to go some gold
teeth Deion Sanders is back in the day
the RDI were pulling it out I just want
one with my kid's name in it my girl
name is the bottom one said I was all
think I could get that I want but I
remember my cousin sending me about
jewelry he was just like yo jewelry you
could put it back and you can make money
off of what I was just I okay whatever
I'm not really into that you know I
gotta clean and keep up with it but I'm
just saying to your point I think they
need to hear some of us are sabotaging
ourselves because we're trying to keep
up with the Joneses or we try to have a
certain image and it's like yo you could
get a Ford Fusion to do what you're
doing I'm saying cuz you parking it and
you spend an eight to ten I was just
somebody job anything like you driving
that sucker around on a regular basis so
I think for a lot of us if we would stop
trying to keep up with the Joneses and
we would build our self-esteem up we
could save money and then from that like
you said we could start you know come on
I'm just saying cuz I hear people say
all the time I need to make million I'm
like yo I'm gonna be real with you you
don't need to make millions that live
like a millionaire like I promise you
that life that you're talking about you
really don't need to ball out of control
like that to have a life where you have
your time president you read on route
number 26
don't confuse goals with dreams here's
the deal you from now on if it's
something personal call it a gold thrill
let's let's let's get the terminology
right if you want a car we're gonna name
that it that's a goal
don't put your car in the same category
as my Luther King when he said I have a
dream don't put down put that in the
same category that's different category
if you're trying to build your business
portfolio that's the goal when you use
the word
dream now you were changing other
people's lives when dr. Moses the King
said I have a dream he'd already had a
PhD when he said I have a dream he was
already a minister at Ebenezer Baptist
Church when he said I have a dream he
already had a car when he said I have a
dream he already had a wife when he said
I have a dream he already had children
when he said I have a dream he had
already won the Nobel Prize when he said
I have a dream he had already met with
the president when he said I have a
dream
he was already one of the most
influential people on the planet when he
said I have a dream he wasn't talking
about himself he was talking about you
and I and so I want you to redefine when
you say money you say go say I have a
goal I have a target when you say I have
a dream that's beyond you rule number 27
get yourself to the next level when I
was doing a PhD and one of the
professor's bless her heart she know no
better
she probably grew up privileged or
something so she didn't know so she read
my paper and was like I don't think
you're gonna be able to pass the
dissertation and I knew where she was
coming from like I wouldn't like she
know hater but what she was doing was
saying as a critical thinker based on
where you are right now
she had the slightest idea I was getting
better every day so you taught you
talking to me about Who I am right now
we even doing a dissertation yet you're
talking to me about something we gonna
do a year and a half from now you had a
slice idea I'm not gonna be the same
version I will not be the same person in
a year and a half that I am right now
well I wouldn't be sitting in your class
you know I need you to hear what I'm
saying you are too old to be sitting
somebody classroom trying to get a grade
we're a pass Bray's y'all
that's like elementary school you won't
get a star some that's Elementary School
you also might take you out for ice
cream
cuz you did what you supposed to do it's
a different level when I went out listen
to me when I went to college I didn't go
to college but nobody degree I realized
that grown up in Detroit Michigan my mom
worked for Ford my father who wasn't my
biological father worked for GM I knew
where I was called to be and what I was
called to do my parents could only take
me so far I went to the classroom to
find the language that I needed to get
to the next level I wanted to hear what
you know hey what I'm telling you I
already knew I was gonna be successful
but I didn't have some of the language
so I was going to class and look how
they put citizens together I was looking
to find out when you put this word and
this word how you style you're not hear
what I'm telling you I wasn't going for
nobody grades and still got good grades
but I wasn't going for grades I was
going for the cold what's the code I
need to know the code
what's the cold move number 28 but come
a shark somebody asked me like Joey
how do you stay fired up brah you've
been doing this since she was 19 it
seemed like there me and dad were there
bad I mean your dad was talking he was
like II I listen to so many other
motivational speakers eat and it just
seemed like you get better and better I
say I get better and better because the
thing that pumped me up in the beginning
is the thing I think about every day I
wake up every day like yo you gotta take
control brah because if you don't take
control we live in a society outside of
your house you live in a world full of
sharks this world is run primarily by
sharks and I promise you if you don't
become one they will eat you alive
rule number 29 be specific you gotta be
specific you gotta say I'm gonna make
three hundred and twenty five thousand
four hundred and eighty two dollars a
year
it's being realist you got to say now
you gotta say it like you got to get
away the exact you can't be like I want
to be rich in the world like I don't
know what that is I don't know what rich
is I don't know what that means
are you hearing me rule number 30 start
playing big this is what's so crazy like
even as I stand here like I can't
believe I'm in Columbus Ohio like I
can't believe I'm with Lewis Howes like
I can't believe I went to some of the
greatness like guys I was I was just
homeless like I was just literally
sleeping in abandoned buildings I was
literally just thinking about committing
suicide right and so so what happened
was I was introduced I was probably
about 16 almost 17 and I was introduced
to a pastor a friend of mine took me to
church with him and it was the oddest
thing I went to church maybe about three
or four times and I didn't grow up in
church so I wasn't really there for like
the religious aspect of it but this was
my best friend and this is where he went
regularly right and I loved it it kind
of reminds me of this summit you know it
was a lot of positive people right first
time in my life being in an environment
with just positivity right they would
sing and the pastor would speak and we'd
have a dinner after every church service
I think that's probably why I went cuz
it was like a meal really himself when
you homeless and your high school
dropout you in that trash can like a hot
meal is just unbelievable right that's
why I'm a foodie to this day right and
so but I'll never forget he would say to
me you know maybe maybe three or four
weeks into going regularly you know he
said to me kid what are you doing with
your life I'm like what does that mean
exactly
he's like what what's your goals what
your dreams like I don't have any goals
any dreams like my biological father
wasn't in my life my mom got pregnant
with me at 17 years old like I don't
come from what you know what we call
like the older meals experience you know
I'm not like you know my
great-grandfather a picture with my
grandfather then my father and me like I
don't I don't know what I want to do and
I remember maybe about the second month
of coming to church he would say to me
he'd say you know what you need to get
your GED and you need to go to college
and I was like what like don't you know
I'm living like I'm living in abandoned
buildings like I'm working at McDonald's
and I'm eating McDonald's like got
like my mother is 717 when she had me
she didn't finish height well she barely
finished high school she didn't go to
college my grandma had 14 kids none of
them went to college like we don't do
college you know and it was just so
weird this is why you need to be in this
type of environment because this
environment activates and give you
permission to do I'm sorry I get excited
because I'm not supposed to be on this
stage listen to me I was literally
homeless I was coming to church not
really taking showers
I wasn't brushing my teeth and this
guy's looked at me and said you need to
get your GED you need to leave the troit
I'm gonna sing you to college cuz
greatness is upon you guys that's why
this environment is so important because
what he did was he allowed me to see who
I was before I could really see who I
was and he saw guys I just we just
buried him about four weeks ago and and
and he saw something in me like like
everybody in the world now says like you
know et I watch your video and this
happened an AB and et you know I get
inspired I was 16 17 years old I had
never spoken a day in my life and this
guy saw it like he saw something to me
that I didn't see and he gave me
permission to be where other people said
I couldn't be he gave me permission to
believe I was great he gave me
permission to think I could change the
world he gave me permission to start
something that had never started in my
family before he gave me permission to
say he gave me permission to say I am
brilliant oh yeah I might be different
but I am brilliant yep I might be loud
but I am special he gave me permission
and so the first thing I want you to do
today is I want you to keep saying to
yourself I am I am I am I am and for
those of you who hadn't quite started
yet I am and for those of you who gotten
started I am why because I can't believe
that I started with a GED and that GED
turned into a four-year degree took me
12 years guys it took me 12 years but
pastor will keep telling me you are
brilliant you are special Eric yes
you're different and yes you're not
doing it the traditional route but
greatness is upon you you got to keep
going you got to keep going you got to
keep going in the 12 years to get the
four-year degree turn into a master's
degree and the master's degree turn into
a PhD guys I can't believe it I went
from being a high school dropout from
being homeless living in abandoned
buildings to eating out of trash cans to
dr. Eric Thomas to riding six books guys
are you hearing what I'm saying
today stop playing small and start
playing big because ah rule number 31
don't be average when you look at a lion
in the Serengeti when the lion wakes up
in the gazelle wakes up they both have
to run like it just because you're a
lion doesn't mean you get to chill out
the Gazelle is not gonna come to you and
let it eat you you still got a hunt you
still have to go get it yeah but the but
the crazy part when I did my homework
because the Gazelle is running for its
life the lion is running to hunt and to
eat so I realized there are a lot of
people reading these books listening to
these different you know motivational
speakers but they don't understand that
you got to go get it
so it's not enough to read it it's not
enough to understand it is not enough to
get excited about it like literally it
has to transform you and so I start
realizing like ill eat a problem is you
have been working hard mm-hmm you know
you've been getting me eat you've been
putting for for a hundred and like not a
percent 19-foot 120% but guys what I
realize is not just what you do eat its
effort and technique so if you're
lifting weights but you're lifting them
wrong I mean you could go lifting
weights every day but if you're not if
your technique is off like you don't
know how to do it then you're not gonna
I'm not gonna get the same results you
get doing the exam exact exercise so I
realized II you got to switch the effort
like you can't give 80 on Monday 90 on
two
1:20 on Thursday like every day you wake
up you got to keep that same effort so I
would I would notice when I would go to
like watch Alabama play against maybe
like a Mississippi State I would notice
that Alabama came out on fire in all
four quarters these boys are going but I
would notice Mississippi would come out
strong but if they went down by 14 you
saw the body language changed they came
back after halftime strong fourth
quarter fatigue kicked in and I started
realizing Cole you know if I get 120
first quarter second quarter third
quarter fourth quarter if my effort and
my technique is both stroke I'm not
nobody's gonna stop me why because the
average person Monday they come into
work sluggish and they got to drink
their coffee they got to read their
newspaper I'm like oh I got you beat you
didn't get started in to 9 o'clock
I'm coming in at 1:20 at 8:00 and by 9
o'clock when you get going it's gonna
take you to noon to get to a hunnit then
you gotta take a break come back but I'm
not taking off at lunch all right I'm
not taking off at lunch and then at 5
o'clock you packing your bags at 4:30
getting ready to leave I'm running not
to the rivet I'm running through it
rule number 32 do you how many kids in
this room that's some stuff you did come
on Kenny
how about what's the stuff you did when
he was 18 19 that you wouldn't have done
if you weren't trying to impress nobody
if you was just being you I'm thinking
like how many mistakes that we made
trying to be what they want us to be
what if we can just be who we were like
what would we be doing if we weren't
worried about them so I'm challenging
you when you walk out of this room I'm
challenging you to do you I'm
challenging you to do you rule number 33
change your perception let me tell y'all
something I'm number one motivational
speaking the were let me tell you how
why we started the advantage 2005 we
blew up I'm still doing the advantage
every Monday every Tuesday at Michigan
State University people like me you blew
up you're doing listen to me so bad I'm
telling the people that book my gigs
don't book don't book no gigs on Monday
try your heart is not the book no gigs
on Monday eat why you got a chance to
make thousand thousands of dollars why
would you - no I got
stage I gotta stay close to the place
that blew me up I gotta stay this is the
grand cause I'm just keepin the 100-yard
as the company we have blown up there
are people in our company they used to
do one thing they're doing something
totally different I guarantee you I'm
doing exactly what I was doing from day
one and I have not changed and the
reason why some of you aren't successful
is because the value you had that thing
when you first started doing it you
don't have that same value no more you
don't treat that thing the way you used
to treat that thing when you first got
that thing and so what God is saying is
I need you to change your perception
because once you change your perception
everything changes sudden wants to
change your perception the value changes
and once the value changes the energy
that you give it is totally different
rule image 34 have a strong why so I
always hear people again they say 'hey
what's your wife people hear me say that
so I did the Kevin Durant boy the video
blew up and so now you know people are
asking everybody well sure why what sure
why mm-hmm but I think that is the
that's the starting point Cole I was
watching ESPN 30 for 30 and the video
that I did on Mike Tyson and Buster
Douglas 30 for 30 just they really did
that BT the video idea they turned it
into a documentary and it is the story
of Buster Douglas beating Mike Tyson
nobody is ever beating before and when
they asked the question how my mom died
and I and I told my mom I would beat
Mike Tyson mm-hmm again the next fight
he lost the Buster he lost to Evander
Holyfield and he never was a champion
again but that one day he got knocked
down got back up why because of his
mother and I think again I want to show
people because the common theme is you
do it for a house you do it for a car
you're do it for a watch you know you do
it for and I want to show people that
whether you know it or not everybody
doesn't have the same why rule number 35
take ownership that's what I need you to
do for me I need you to tape from three
Oh Millennials y'all kill me with the
blame game what move are you going to
make today to get out your circumstance
what time are you gonna get up what job
are you gonna do who are you gonna hang
out with Millennials all you gotta do is
say you know what I'm taking ownership I
don't care my mom a good mom or a bad
mom if my dad a good dad or a bad dad
I don't care about going to the best
food with the worst food I don't care if
we rich or poor I am about to take
ownership of my life at this point four
is your life and you can do my friend
with whatever you want to do with it
rule number 36 never say no if you want
to get paid you never say no you never
say it can't get done don't you ever say
out your mouth it can't get done even if
you feel in your heart it can't get done
you all say it out loud you let the
broke folk say that you let the folks
they fire first say that you always say
it could get done even if you don't
think it could get done just say it and
try to make up something I'm being real
I'm being real I don't I don't deal with
people who say or they get paid real low
and my company they like maintenance
when you say I don't know how or I don't
think it could be done like okay cool
you won't be like at the end of the year
when bonuses getting passed out you
won't be getting no bonus rule number 37
model success so when you look at et
yeah I might be one of the top speakers
in the world but when you look at the
other guys that you look at me you see
it some different you see that you see
the shoes and so what I've been able to
do is take the stuff from Zig Ziglar
take this stuff from Tony Robbins take
this stuff from Les Brown when I was
younger and listen Nightingale like I'm
listening to the same people Napoleon
Hill
I'm gonna send who everybody else is
listening to but I'm not just listening
and going do exactly what they say i'm
saying 'hey you got to customize it you
got to make it work for you you got to
make it fit in your language you got to
make it fit for your audience you got to
make it fit for you rule number 38 don't
surround yourself with takers but i told
me to tell you to stop making plates for
people who just trying to take it to go
write that down
no God told me to tell you stop making
for poopoo for folks that just wanted to
go plate he told me to tell you that
there's somebody in the room your life
is screwed up because you're making food
for people who just wanted to go plate
you you I'm come on you be it your life
you are a great person good person you
phenomenal you got it going on
you making all these great meals and
it's a whole bunch of people come to
your house and they got it to go
container and they listen to me very
closely my grandma taught me when I was
young my grandma had 14 kids who all had
kids and my god myself will cut you you
can eat as much food as you want at the
house but if I swear one of the other
Joker's takes so much this house are you
getting the business in front of your
mama in front of you because I used to
whip day but I'm whipping your blood too
with a switch don't take no food out of
my house you can eat as much as you want
when you here but do not pack a plate
and most of y'all running with people
who when you fix food they come to your
house and take it to go play they don't
bring nothing they not trying to help
you all and your life to do is take take
take take take take take and you wonder
why your life messed up because you were
takers rule number 39 put in the work
I'll never forget I said god I won't be
one of the best at what I do I want to
change lives and I got a call from Les
Brown and I'm flew to go meet Les Brown
say ET you should be making at least
$50,000 in to nationally and $100,000
internationally that's like what feels
like you're a kid you could so I went
homes like God why make it be done is
there we watching the World Series
because you're watching the NBA Finals
because you watching football and you
watch it three game you're watching the
one o'clock game the 4:30
8:00 p.m. day and you watch here's being
to rewatch everything you watch that's
why you ain't successful you watching
LeBron make his dreams become a reality
you watching the Black Mamba make his
dreams become right if you put the same
time LeBron foot in it and I started
studying and I realized I was an
african-american male I need to get a
master's degree and a PhD in order to do
what I'm doing and guess what I had to
get up even though it was hard and I had
to take ownership of my life take
ownership of my time take ownership of
my day
rule number 40 keep it real aggressive
people finish first it is what it is
y'all from New York you know I'm talking
about
I'm just for real you come to New York I
promise you if you don't want to get
harassed stay in the house I'm come on
you in New York and I'm come on you in
New York is 80 degrees
my man likes unclad sunglasses brought
he needs to sunglasses I'm like I'm good
on sunglasses brother it started raining
he liked my ba-boom you want to umbrella
might yeah you got breath job said they
don't be playing in New York they got
everything for everything my mails I
also listen to the podcast I heard your
girl got your man I got the jelenia on
discount bro I'm not gonna discount on
discount bro y'all look great and it
ain't like you like I'm good on it son
glad no bra sunglass he's certain like
I'm good on that no bra sunglasses
I'm like no bruh I'm good on the Sun
glad you sure bruh I'm like I'm sure how
you just got aggressive like you gonna
make me buy the glasses so I had to
realize I was delusional I thought if
you were a good person and you do right
by people that people will take your
kindness and extend give you kindness
back but what I realized is sometimes in
this world
the kinder you are the more they try to
play you like a fool I was delusional
I'm nice to you you nice to me don't
always work like that sometimes it's
nice to me and I take advantage of you
so some of y'all you delusional
I just need you do me a favor when you
are delusional you can never get the
outcomes you want because you the
premise in which you're operating from
is a lie so you got to work from truth
and some of us don't want to deal with
truth because it's so difficult et you
dropped out of school et you grew up in
a certain community in order for you to
be able to do what you need to do like a
Tony Robbins there's some things that
you don't have in your arson that if you
can just admit you don't have it in your
arson then you can go get it but until
you admit that you don't have it you'll
never be able to do it
so I need you to mean huge favor I just
need you to be real and the reason why a
lot of y'all don't want to be real
because some of you would rather be in a
lie and at least have a lie and not have
anything at all you already know the
reality about that relationship you
already know that job you invited your
boss ain't bout to cash you out you're
just scared to quit and start your own
business because you don't know if
you're gonna do well or not you know you
shouldn't come on be honest you know you
still shouldn't be at that job right now
let me see your hands let's just be real
let me see your hand
you know you should still raise it high
don't play with me raise it high you
still shouldn't be at that job but
you're delusional that one day it's
gonna be your day that one day you're
gonna merge your job and you'll get your
calling together it's not gonna happen
you gonna have to just leave rule number
41 do not be outworked so I'm working
with the Cleveland Cavaliers I'm talking
about I've been getting up at 3 o'clock
in the morning
I'm putting videos out I'm doing my
thing I never forget y'all I never
forget so I looked at the best of the
best motivational speakers and I told
y'all what I saw right
one time we ordered one of the top
motivational speakers we ordered some of
his content like I'm stuck I'm studying
I'm studying my competition my man I'm
talking my he fire he wanted the best of
the best but I called my man I wanted to
get one of his DVD series one of the CDs
how long do you think it took for me to
pay for it and then how long you think
he can't it took to come how long don't
say forever give me a time frame a month
you have three weeks to a month I
studied my competition I'm like that oh
my man fire my man fire my man
Oh fire my man Oh his use of word oh my
man his presence oh this is phenomenal
but when I studied all them it take
three weeks to a month to get this stuff
I said bingo I got them I got them I'm
going YouTube and give my stuff away
because guess what if you're going
through a divorce you ain't got three
weeks to wait on the doggone video if
your momma got cancer you got cancer you
ain't got three weeks to a month to wait
for your video so I'm saying they they
better than me but they will not outwork
me I will get up every day and put some
on anybody ever been on YouTube but you
saw some of my stuff on you too
just raise your hand you ever saw my
stuff did you see my stuff come on in 10
o'clock in the morning come on be real
you have to see my stuff coming to 8
o'clock in the morning now my stuff
coming in 3 o'clock at the door good
morning I'm doing it everyday and 3
o'clock in the morning I'm telling y'all
the breakthrough I'm gonna break these
boys why because where they come from
they couldn't get up at 3 o'clock in the
morning they wanted to they smarter than
me they come from privilege they got the
language they got the cold they got the
rules they grew up in it but they will
not get up earlier than me they will not
put out more content to me be smoke 1 2
be slow 1 2 3 he's slow 1 2 3
peaceful I be small my way to number one
I'll be small my way to number one rule
number 42 man I'm talking to the Creator
three o'clock in the morning and I am
where I want to be and I'm like God I am
where I want to be and he was like you
stop being a victim
so what you mean a victim well hey my
fault my mom got pregnant 17 hey my
fault my daddy went there it ain't my
fault they couldn't get along it ain't
my fault he said boy you you grown
you ain't ten no more you the decisions
you make right now is up to you you
crying about something happened to you
when you was a kid
you ain't even no kid no more you're a
grown man take ownership the stupid your
parents and make you play no video games
and what you crying about
so what your daddy wasn't it your mama
end up getting married what you crying
about he went to work every day you
never beat you never use you your mama
did the best she knew how to do what you
crying about you grew up in a house what
you crying about
it was never sexually assaulted what you
crying about
- somebody beat your bucket you did
something you weren't supposed to do
what you crying about nobody just came
home and start whipping you principle
number two man up stop crying
rule number 43 wanted bad enough when
you want to succeed as bad as you wanna
breathe young man then you will be
successful in any area of your life and
so listen to me very closely I say this
to you
I never said when you want to succeed as
bad as you want to eat cuz you can go 21
days maybe 30 if you're Gandhi or
Gandhi's mother without eating fast you
can fast for 30 days I never said it
when you want to succeed as bad as you
want water because you can go about
three days or so without it I said when
you want to succeed as bad as you want
to breathe
you've probably only got a minute or so
then you'll be successful
rule number 44 fight for your
breakthroughs so everybody always asked
me et what was it like being homeless I
don't remember what was it like eating
out of trash cans I don't remember I
ain't on that let me tell y'all the
hardest part of my life the hardest part
of my
life was not being homeless I had no
dreams of no goals I didn't want nothing
eating out of trash cans wasn't the
hardest thing I've ever done the hardest
thing I ever did was get my GED go to
college study every dog all day and
still fail that's hard that's hard when
you write in the paper for 3-4 weeks you
turn it in and you can still get a 2.0
that's hard it's hard when you're in a
library you studying and you read and
you take the test and you get a 55
that's hard so what I want you to
understand about a breakthrough is that
90% is work but the last 10% that's
fight listen to me you don't get a
breakthrough by working you get a
breakthrough when you fight and I had to
fight I had to stay up all night
rule number 45 break your bad habits I'm
asking you to do me a favor whatever
your favorite TV programs are don't
watch them cuz that's why you are where
you are right now whatever they are
don't what call your home you say I know
we cool but just give me 30 days I just
need 30 days by myself
but every Sunday we let's break that
tradition because we both broke and
we've been doing that for 15 years let's
stop doing it on Sundays real like it
ain't working rule number 46 take care
of yourself first so the first thing I
want you to do for real I need you to
take care yourself and the way we burn
out is that we put everybody else first
and then what happens is the plane is
crap
this is teachers I love us the plane is
crashing and we're putting the oxygen
check on everybody else and they're
taking it and taking theirs so they're
sucking theirs
and they're got they have yours I need
you to do me a favor number one when you
leave today I need you to take care of
yourself right and I need you to know
that if you don't take care of every
single thing some kind of way will be
taken care of
but if you burn out we already lost rule
number 47 master your craft I will get
to a place in my life that when you ask
me et what do you do professionally I
will tell you that I energize I am a
performer performance enhancer I'm the
juice you walking about you you you come
in my room diamond out when you leave
you ready to run through a wall it took
me years to be able to say one word or
one phrase to get people to understand I
develop people personally and
professionally I develop I used to say I
have a problem being linear it takes me
too long to say well one person because
I would be like whoa that's deep so my
ask my man a question ten seconds he
would answer it they would ask me I'd be
like a minute 15 like I can't get it I'm
trying to said say I'm trying to narrow
this thing down and somebody came up to
me like what's going on here I was like
yo I'm struggling with the okay let's go
through some exercises that can help you
I'm still not where I want to be but I'm
a whole lot better let me give you an
example somebody say eat in your
conference you charge in two thousand
dollars when you come to Phoenix like
I'm thinking about doing day - but it's
two thousand dollars brother like what
stood in between day one day two I was
like in day two we gonna customize he's
like customized I was like he had called
me Tony Starks I said see Superman
whether he got on a outfit or not he's
still Superman he was born with natural
abilities you weren't born there execute
you're not Superman but I'm Tony Stark's
I'll make a suit that will make you a
super executor and it for those of you
who really know Tony Stark's he just
didn't make himself asleep you made
spider-man a suit and I'll be your
Alfred Batman you are a normal person
but I'll make your suit your car you're
more he's like you know what do I sign
up
eat I'm all over the place I need that
customized I got you boom I know I'm say
anyway now we're simplifying some I can
understand you in 30 seconds rule number
48 but come a beast Mike Tyson wall
before he fought you know you don't you
don't win a fight when you fight you win
if you obese you win the fight before
the fight so go back to your homes and I
want you to go on your little machines I
put my Dyson and you will watch Mike
Tyson I'm sure about for real when you
hear the word Iron Mike Tyson you think
my man coming out six to 250 pounds Mike
Tyson come out my man about 510 511
he looking up to do is like what and we
might look at them in a face Mike look
at him like I swear you don't want then
it is I swear I promise you when the
bell ring when I hit you once you just
better fall because if you do not fall I
promise you you will feel pain like you
would never felt before my man wasn't
six eight my man one toy he wasn't being
my but my man was a beast and when they
would go deep ding ding ding my bop bop
and boom they fall go back and watch it
like I used to be pissed me and my boys
paid $50 we pay fee that we got the
snacks we got the wings we got we got we
ready for the fight y'all I'm keeping
them all right playing
ask somebody over to you I'm come on we
go like oh the fight box come on 25 get
your eye on go grab the wing we go grab
the wings and come back my boy like he
is over I'm like you lying bro you know
how long it took me to make that $50 at
the Olive Garden no chips bruh Hulan her
bra is over is like he is over eat soon
as they hit the bell Mike came out boom
boom boom
overdone so what I need y'all to do man
he mono e mono man the man I need y'all
the first week y'all come out I need
y'all to come out so doggone strong then
that when teams come on the field come
on don't just say it
lock the gate don't just say it don't
just say it sound cute you wearing a
t-shirt don't just say it
lock that joke for real get to the point
this season that when they come out on
the field they're like we only one of
this rule number 49 find your gift that
finally has 16 I left home ran away from
home of course left school and I
remember going to church I didn't grow
up in church I start going to church and
I remember the pastor said to me young
man
if you have any dreams any goals if you
don't want to go to jail if you don't
want to die in the early age you have to
get your GED and go to college now
listen to me very closely my grandma had
14 kids out of the 40 only 3 finished
high school and nobody went to college
I grew up in Detroit Michigan culturally
college is not important why it does not
make sense to go to college whether you
finish high school or not you're only
gonna land up at the plant for GM or
Chrysler so culturally I never took
school serious and so this man said to
me
he said to me when I was probably 70
years old look every single week did you
get your GED and I would say no I didn't
get my GED he'd asked me the next week
did you get your GED as soon as you get
your GED I'm sending you out of Detroit
I'm sending you to college
I said sir no disrespect but my family
does not do college my mama barely
finished high school she got pregnant
with me her senior in high school my
grandma didn't go to school my uncles
didn't fit we don't do school he said I
don't care what your family does or does
not do you have a gift you have an
anointing on your life young man and
rule number 50 the last for me for a
very social bonus clip is take action
all of you are gonna get the information
but some of you aren't gonna do anything
with it somebody's sitting in this room
just like I said in the room as a high
school dropout I got my GED I went to
Huntsville Alabama I went to Oakwood
college and that man got up and he spoke
and when he spoke it changed my life not
because of his words but because of his
words and who I was at the time I was
ready there were other people sitting in
there I'm telling you listen to me y'all
this is crazy
if you go back to my college in 1989 I
was already a year behind it took me 12
years to get a four-year degree and I
was definitely not the most likely to
succeed but when you put down the Hall
of Famers of the people that went to the
school you got to include me listen to
me very closely you got to hear what I'm
telling you I had come from sleeping on
the streets and abandoned buildings
eating out of trash cans
I had gone as a high school dropout who
got his GED so we were all in the same
room some of us didn't want to be there
some of us did but the way I took the
information the way I process the
information took me
from what listen to me I was getting
this information as a high school
dropout but I was getting it and I was
doing some with it other people were
getting it was like I wasn't that deep
or I is deep but I'll apply it later I'm
telling you that as much as ignite that
dream is going to ignite your dream some
of your other then gonna ignite your
dream and there's nothing wrong with the
message it's something wrong with you
and so some of you are gonna walk out of
here I promise you on everything I love
you gonna walk out of this place and a
year from today you're gonna wake up
like told and not even believe what
happened to your life there are those of
you right now you ain't rock bottom you
spent your last dollar to get to this
place like you are you are at a
crossroad and if you take this
information and you do something with it
it's gonna change your life forever
now I've got a special bonus clip from
Eric on how to be in control that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
is time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching a
video to taking action here we go number
one what's the most important action
that you need to take today right after
watching this video number two who are
the takers in your life that you need to
stop being surrounded by and number
three what are your goals and what are
your dreams now if you like this video
and you're gonna take some action after
watching it give me a hashtag believe
down the comments below more teenagers
and young adults die from suicide than
from cancer that self what that self
what good that self inflicted so that
people who lose ago we got teenagers out
here committing suicide it's more than
this that more teenagers are died than
AIDS birth defect stroke pneumonia and
flu or influenza chronic lung disease
combined you take all this and you've
got more kids killing themselves than
them getting diseases and die we are
losing control and it's time for those
of you in this room to take control I
told you right someday you could be
living this some day you've held up your
someday either you didn't get the right
information or you got it you didn't use
it you know
getting up early enough you're not
taking it back I don't know what you're
doing but when you leave all I want for
you is to live your some day if you want
more Eric Thomas check out the first top
fifty rules video I made on him the link
is right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there once y'all win it all
do you even know like do you know what
you'll win it all is for this year you
have been blessed by the created the
beyond are you here